hello everybody
let's see who's built coming in
thank you i'm sorry we're starting just
after seven so everyone should be
shuffling in right now
i will give everyone a few moments just
to make sure
they all come in because they're all
starting to flow in right now
i don't know how much of that is just
counter lag versus actually
uh people coming in so let's give it a
few moments
we'll sit here in awkward silence and i
won't make awkward silence i'll make an
awkward noise
instead as we get going
all right hello from chicago jim welcome
jim
where else where else we have people
coming from
i i see some people i went to high
school with even actually
boston toronto hey it's a wumba
queensland
hey found a native for you calgary
brisbane look at bringing out all the
aussies
but touching oh rob is here hi rob
ken brooks good to see you from
connecticut
this might be the most australian crowd
we've ever had it's a good
time slot tampa hanover
mexico a lot of melbourne i can't
pronounce it melbourne or
brisbane i can't pronounce it with your
accent yeah
uh bridgewater we have folks all over i
think there's also selection bias here
all the people who are just
in new york probably aren't saying hi as
much
because they're always there you know
all right so it seems like we had a good
inflow
lexington from all philly
great seeing everybody okay
so now that it's starting to steady off
the amount of people
coming in we will get going a little bit
so welcome everybody to the kickoff for
our week i'm always very excited this is
our sixth year we are doing the
conference
and we always like just to make it that
much harder and stressful for all of us
to host a meet up the same week
as the conference just make it a
jam-packed
in the years past we've done two days of
conference and a meet up now we're doing
a meet up two days of workshops and two
days of conference so it's
five days of our this week uh tomorrow's
only respite we have is a way to get
settled and get going on it so we're
very very excited for this
so welcome again to another virtual
meetup
uh i want to thank ecohealth alliance
for giving us the zoom link that's
always a big help
that's very very helpful and
we want to you know welcome you all
hopefully we'll see a lot of you the
rest of this week
the first thing we always do when we're
in person is ask about
jobs who is hiring so since it's in
it's impractical to have everyone sort
of shout jobs at us and zoom
if you can if you can go to the ny hack
our slack
at nyhakar.slack.com
go there and go to the job postings
channel
and put your job there we over the past
decade we've gotten so many people's
jobs simply by saying who's hiring
and having companies raise their hands
so we want to continue that
even though we are not in person so
please go to the job postings channel
and post
any jobs you might have we love getting
people jobs
again another thing we like doing which
we unfortunately can't do together
anymore
is our pizza poll so this month
i got from a place called nomad pizza as
you can see it's neapolitan style with
some good char crust
as a good chip oh if the cheese lock
fell apart the cheese lock did not hold
in place that's good to know there's not
a lot of cheese lock
it's a decent place i'm actually it's
first i'm eating i like this like so i
shouldn't say it's decent place it's
decent because i
just saw it i will taste this a little
bit and see how good it is i hope
everyone here is having pizza
along with me or other favorite food i
hope you're enjoying that
miles if you're not aware we do a
opinion poll on pizza every single month
so we had to have pizza delivered
very important part of what we do here
this week as i mentioned nyr we still
have a few days
if you want to buy tickets we have
workshops wednesday and thursday
different workshops
we have gis and mapping we have
using git we have even a scikit-learn
workshop we have a shiny and dataviz
workshop
we have a tidyverse workshop and a web
scraping workshop
and of course there was a machine
learning website in our but that sold
out
so we still have those and the
conference itself is friday through
saturday
if you want tickets use code ny hack r
for 20 discount because this conference
is really meant to be this meetup
extended over two full days and just a
big party for r uh when we
do it in person it really we have live
mute not lives we have recorded music
we have ice cream we have pizza it's a
real party um so we're gonna try to
recreate as much of that as we can
virtually and try to make it as much fun
as possible
next month we are going to have a meet
up about
using the the command line and the
terminal uh we're going to don't have
the exact date yet
but it's going to be a really fun talk
all about using tmux and vim
and setting up your terminal environment
and
making it just uh much more usable
because i know a lot of our users
feel comfortable with the r console but
they don't necessarily feel comfortable
at a terminal at like a linux terminal
so this is a talk that hopefully help a
lot of you get more and more comfortable
because i know myself
still to this day but especially when i
started i could use r but as soon as i
got to the terminal i was like oh am i
going to mess up my computer
so i'm really excited to have this talk
we also have a talk schedule in october
not the exact date yet
but coming all the way from our speaker
is going to be coming from scotland
i don't think we can have anyone coming
from farther away than australia i think
that's like
that's the farthest physical point on
earth and they don't exactly quote me on
that example the farthest point
on earth right now is actually the
middle of the ocean but probably the
farthest away as planes go
is probably australia so with that i do
want to say
thank you to our speaker coming up and
the way this occurred was
he was posting about stuff about drake
on twitter
i'm like this is awesome i want to learn
more about drake i pestered him with so
many questions over the span of a few
days
and he patiently answered all my
questions very nicely
and and then i said okay no good deed
goes unpunished how would you like to
talk at the meet up
and he uh graciously agreed to work in
the time zones that it's 9 a.m for him
so we are very excited that he made it
all the way here just one more
logistical
uh thing before we get started i see a
bunch of people are asking questions in
the zoom webinar probably the slack
channel ahmad i believe we created a
slack channel
uh for this uh meetup uh the name
the name of it is would you mind running
that by me
um so the name
of it is today's date so
um one moment
should be august
i'm actually renaming it now august 10
meet up
august 10 meet up so folks if you have
questions the way this kind of works is
it's hard to everyone ask questions and
miles because we're all digital
if you could post your questions in the
slack channel august 10th meetup
or here in the zoom webinar chat i'll do
my best to collate all of them
and ask all the questions at the end
this has worked out for us so far
so please go ahead and ask every
question you've got in the slack channel
or here on the zoom webinar
so just to recap they become an r week
hope you're enjoying pizza at home
i saw someone already posted a job in
job postings keeps that keep that up
september meetup is about the terminal
uh the october meetup is
going to be really awesome too learn
more about that next month and
everyone welcome from the other side of
the world i guess other side
halfway around the world uh miles mcbain
thank you very much for being here with
us
um yeah thank you for having me um yeah
look it is a real honor and i'm
like stoked to be warming up the crowd
for the art conference
um and uh you know look you're
uh you're still in my bucket list new
york um i do want to get to the our
conference myself and and this meet
but you know virtually is what we've got
to do for now uh and yeah that should
work pretty well i think for this
for this presentation i've put together
okay so what are we talking about
um i'll just get my screen share going
all right can you see a presentation
i'm assuming that's good can someone say
yes
yes yes all right good
okay so uh yeah what i want to do with
this talk is kind of
explore some different project workflow
styles
and my objective is simply to give you a
fresh way to understand
the strengths and weaknesses of
different project workflow styles
and hopefully some new ideas you can
take on um and use in your own workflows
so the outline so i want to talk about
workflows as tools for enjoyment
and then i want to explore some sort of
some of the main workflow styles that
people use
and then yeah i want to talk about the
workflow style that my team use which is
drake and d flow um just briefly because
i want to do more of a demo
on that so let's go
um oh that's gone to the very last slide
for some reason hang on sorry
all right all right first thing is an
exercise
um i want you to recall a time when you
had the most fun
whilst working and i don't mean like you
were on slack and you were laughing at
gifts you guys are sending each other or
your people were sending each other i
mean
simultaneous to the act of working you
were feeling kind of playful joyful
delighted feelings
i want you to really recall this memory
so where you were
who was there what you were doing how
you were doing it
okay so i think you should keep hold of
this memory and you know maybe um
swap it with someone else in the meetup
later on because your answers i think
might surprise
each other certainly oh man okay so
don't process that button sorry
certainly
um you know this is an interesting
question to reflect on
what's your example sitting at a
computer doing data science
so mine wasn't um so this is a seafood
processing facility in
reyevick iceland i haven't worked in
reality iceland but i worked in a very
similar facility or basically a carbon
copy of this in cairns in north
queensland
and some context is that in australia we
associate seafood with christmas time so
there's this big peak demand
and if you're looking for um you know
seasonal work it's really easy work to
get
and so i did this for a few different a
few seasons over a few years
so let me talk you through what's
happening here um
you know there's a sort of production
line and this person here is making a
cut to take a
a fill it off a big fish this person
here is making a different cut to like
take the skin off that fillet
and i'm pretty sure this person is
either like checking for bones or doing
some sort of portioning cut
so why do i why do i think this is fun
well you're learning a new skill like
learning a knife
learning to use a knife effectively is a
really like nice life skill to have
then i think you know once you can do
that effectively there's a bit of banter
a bit of chat that happens i know these
people are wearing ear muffs but
we didn't have that so you know there's
a bit of camaraderie and you're all
pulling towards a common goal which is
basically like to empty this massive bin
of fish that is like sitting over here
and then you can all go home so that's
that's pretty
you know it's a pretty obvious common
goal you can all look at together
and yeah i think there's a bit of a flow
to it and that's sort of the really
important thing is like for this
production line to work effectively this
has to go like
you know cut for cut for cut you know if
this person's too fast they'll pile up
here if this person's too slow this
person will be waiting
so we've kind of got to get a sense of
like what your what your immediate
team members capabilities are and how
tired they are and what mood they're in
you really got to be pulling together so
if i try and abstract that into a few
points i think you know there's working
with others toward a common goal
there's working with a rhythm or a flow
and there's technical experimentation
with rapid feedback so that's you know
every cut i make i get to see how did i
go what was the yield
should i change my grip should i sharpen
the knife should i change the pitch of
the knife should i change the speed at
which i cut
and all that um you know allows you to
kind of hone in on like a really like
smooth
you know kind of technique um so these
ideas aren't compatible with some
literature workflow
so this is a book um called flow by a
guy called mihai chikset mihai
it's from the 90s maybe some of you read
it um
basically his idea is like he talks
about the difference between pleasure
and enjoyment
and pleasure is this kind of passive
thing and enjoyment is active
and his idea is that we can derive
enjoyment from our work when we're able
to enter this mental state called flow
and some of us might know this as like
being in the zone
um and and so when you're in the zone or
when you're in this flow state
time is distorted we kind of lose focus
on our bodies and our aches and our
pains and
we lose focus on our worries and our
stresses
and we're sort of fully absorbed in
achieving our goal
now mihai says that two things that i
mentioned so having a goal
and having feedback are pretty much
critical to getting it
into this flow state but his sort of
main point is that
there has to be this really good match
between the skills that you have and the
challenges that you're facing
um so you have to feel challenged but
you also have to have the confidence
that you
can overcome this challenge and you know
otherwise
if things are too easy then you're going
to get bored
um and that can lead to sort of
non-productive behavior and if things
are too
too hard you're going to get anxious and
that can lead to other non-productive
behaviors
so i think you know there's a really
natural mapping at least for me between
this and data science like
data science is a you know sense making
profession um
things that make me anxious that when
things don't make sense the question
doesn't make sense the data doesn't make
sense
um and things that make me bored are
when there's no questions to answer
like this is boring i'm just doing like
administrative stuff like where's the
good stuff
and if i think about my daily kind of
work in ah i can quite
easily drop a few things in these
categories right so this is all really
boring things that i just
wish i didn't have to do and these are
like things that make me sort of like
you know they're like the record scratch
like like oh no now i've got to deal
with this like why is this happening i'm
a bit anxious and stressed out right
and so i think you know i want to frame
the role of workflow
to kind of keep us in this zone and the
way that i think workflows do that is
they paper over a lot of this stuff
just completely take it away and you
know you can't take this stuff away but
you can
give people easy kind of access panels
to quote journey brian to
um address some of this stuff and so
yeah i think there are different kind of
main
different types of workflows in use um
for our projects and they
each have kind of different ways that
they balance these these two halves here
so i want to talk about our project
workflow styles
and yeah i'm just zooming in on our
aspect of our work i know like data
science work and statistical work is
much more than like sitting down at the
computer doing r
um you know a lot of it is talking to
people and presenting to people and all
this kind of stuff
um so you can't you can't do that in our
or at least maybe you shouldn't
um and i want to also call out a
collaborator so
um dean mciory i saw him jump into the
the
chat earlier um so he's got this repo
that collects all different kinds of
workflow
tools and papers and blog posts and
stuff and he and i have been like
trying to work on a bit of a write-up
that looks at different r workflow
styles and their strengths and
weaknesses with respect to different
tasks
um and a lot of those ideas are kind of
embedded in this talk in the next
section so the key point for this is i
just want to say like one workflow does
not rule them all so i'm not here to
tell you like
i've come up with the greatest thing and
you should all use it um because it
really depends on what you're doing
what you're making and what your
priorities are you know are you building
an analysis are you answering questions
with data are you
um making production models that you
know score rows in a database and give
them zeros of ones
um depending on whether you think
they'll buy something or click something
or are you building an application that
wraps right around that and shiny allows
people to like
tweak parameters and view forecasts and
stuff
you know so there's a huge universal
stuff we could be building
and then it's also you know like what
are our priorities like we always talk
about reproducibility
but are we talking about reproducibility
five meters away in five minutes time or
are we talking about you know a year
from now 100 years from now
very different sorts of approaches
automation similarly like are we talking
about like semi automation i click a
button and magic happens
um you know a test run or markdown
reports are built are we talking about
like something that runs
fully hands-free in the car in the cloud
automatically ingesting data producing
reports every month
that's very different and this is like
kind of my favorite um
so peer review is pretty important for
our work because
there's a lot of stuff that we do that
is you know you can't write a unit test
for methodology
so the only way i can test my
methodology is to pitch it at a pr and
say you know hey does this make sense
and i might go huh
yeah no that makes sense or nah sorry i
i really don't think that that
will be appropriate um and if we build
our projects to be peer reviewed
as i think we probably should then we're
going to prioritize you know
communication making things clear and
really surfacing like the key kind of
decision points in the project
so the workflow styles i want to run
through so there's notebook um
i didn't really have a good name for
this one so it's called domain specific
folder structure
project is in our package which is a you
know
hot topic at the moment um and target
graphs
so let's talk about notebooks now like
we're probably all well and truly used
to this as a concept now
but i think we really should acknowledge
that combining the presentation layer
and the computational layer
in one document really does save a huge
amount of like boring work
importing and exporting results um
between two different
um tools and you know they they do offer
some
um help with reproducing work because
you know if i render this
then the code that ran is the code that
produced the output and that's like
some guarantee that this thing is going
to be reproducible
so this is you know looking at how how
do notebooks keep us in the flow channel
here like how do they help make our work
enjoyable
so yeah like the you know they save us
from boring importing and exporting
context switching i think is actually a
huge thing like having it all in one
application and being able to see
the thing evolve as they go that's
really important they save us from
reproducibility stuff like they help
um they save it from deciding what to
name all the little
like plots and um tables and stuff like
to export which is really important
and we don't have to learn a markup
language like html or javascript or
lattek
so where are they falling down where are
they creating nickels for us
yeah like i think a lot of these are
related so i'll talk about the one
that's the odd one out first so
abstraction leakage is aware we have an
error that pops up from down in the
stack
so the classic example is um i'm trying
to in
insert a gif into my um you know our
markdown report
and i stuff up the url and i get a
really alien error message from pandoc
that's quite you know confronting to me
so
you know that happens and that's a bit
stressful all these other things are
kind of related to the fact that
caching in notebooks is like a pretty
underdeveloped feature like i know it's
possible in our markdown but if you look
at
the um our markdown manual it basically
says like oh you want to do caching like
yeah you should really go read about
caching validation and the options are
kind of like expert options and they say
things like be careful when you use this
um so it certainly doesn't make any
guarantees and i think because it's hard
a lot of people don't use it and because
people don't use it then they end up in
this situation where they're waiting for
their notebooks to run not to render all
the time and
because that's a problem they end up
over here where they only want to run
small
chunks of work at a time and you end up
with a situation where you like run
chunks out of order
or you run them like too many times they
weren't meant to be run twice in a row
and you get these weird phantom bugs
appearing that each time
this talk which is a pretty good talk
talks a lot about this problem
um the other thing i want to say is like
i don't think these scale very well with
respect to the amount of code
if you have a lot of code um and you try
and jam that into a notebook
what happens is this narrative tension
develops between the code and the text
like you know if you've got like tiered
sql joins
in your in your notebook and then you
you don't want to talk about those you
just want to say like
i got the data and and then i you know
formatted it this way and now i'm doing
my modeling
you won't have to explain like oh yeah i
joined this table and i coalesced this
and i you know
like so basically now we don't we don't
have literate programming
we've got two documents kind of jammed
together but making each other harder to
understand
so when to use notebooks like i think
they work well in the classroom because
they help students and teachers focus on
data science like
their domain specific tool they work
beautifully for exploratory data
analysis because they help you kind of
like do this stream of consciousness
thing you can sort of stay
in the zone focusing on the next plot
the next thing getting that rapid
feedback seeing the document evolve
really good for reports and papers where
there's much more text than code
and actually they work quite nicely for
like simple dashboards
okay so the next thing i want to talk
about is the main specific folder
structures
and here are two um so maybe like it's a
bad name but maybe you can get the
flavor of what i'm talking about here
like basically they provide a neat
structure like a bunch of little boxes
and they say if you put your stuff in
these boxes and you run these
you know commands i will do x thing for
you
so in the case of workflower uh
workflow's thing is basically it wants
to collect
a bunch of um notebooks for you and
publish them into a research website
so you put all your notebooks in here
and it will run them for you and it
totally handles all the back-end stuff
so
it makes commits to git it renders it
into the docs folder and sets that up on
github pages and sets you up with a nice
website
represet represetools is a different
beast it has this kind of gather cook
analyze present workflow and the idea of
this is that
i can put in our markdown documents into
any of these buckets
and then everything that happens in this
bucket is the output for the next bucket
and this analyze bucket only depends on
the outputs
of the cooked bucket so what that what
that means is if i make a change here in
cook
then i can say like you know repress
tools rerun this pipeline i don't
remember what the command is but it'll
it'll look at this and go oh yeah okay
you change something and cook
i don't need to rerun the gather step
i'll just rerun cook analyze present
and what this is doing this is this is
papering over this make file stuff here
and i'll talk a little bit more about
make files later but that's kind of the
flavor
of these tools is that they do they save
you a lot of bookkeeping so in one case
it was get in the other case it was a
make file but it's sort of mainly about
this boring bookkeeping stuff which is
great
um and yeah as we saw they can help you
a little bit with caching so saving
saving work and not re-running it every
time
i think the biggest thing though is like
these things just give you like they
save you having to make a hard decision
about structure decisions about
structure are like i reckon they're even
harder than naming things right
because as the project grows in scope
you know the structure that was
appropriate for a small project is
probably not going to be appropriate for
a big project
and so you need some iterations to kind
of get to a good structure here and
that's painful
so where are we sort of yeah falling
down
well yeah anytime you have a domain
mismatch you're going to be in this sort
of anxious
area that's where you want to do
something that doesn't quite fit neatly
into the boxes
um and yeah i mean one example would be
like oh i want to do
um imputation oh i want to do model
based imputation
oh is that a is that a modeling step or
a data munching step you know there's
all these kind of ambiguities
that can sort of make these things feel
awkward
so when should you use these i think
really when there's a close match with
your domain and your goal
so if you want to make a research
website use workflow if you want to have
a simple workflow with simple caching
that's like pretty easy to understand
use reference tools but if you need more
granularity you're going to need to use
something
more complicated these are some examples
if you look at later
okay so project is in our package yeah
i've written a little bit about this one
recently so there's a blog post there
you can go and have a look at
um i kind of want to defer a lot to that
blog post but yeah look at the short
story is i'm not a big fan of this um i
looked like
you know it barely fits on the slide and
this is a trivial example
um the signal-to-noise ratio is quite
poor i think
and my main gripe is like it's just
it's just the payoff is questionable you
can spend a lot of time on this
beautifully paved highway
getting to an r package complying with
cmd check validating your code with test
matching your description your namespace
shoehorning your results into vignettes
um but
actually you can be nowhere with respect
to achieving your project's goals
and i think if you're going to write
packages for your projects
you know do do better things like
encapsulate analysis
encapsulate algorithms and business
logic into packages so you can share
them between your projects
and maybe if you want that smooth dev
tools use this experience
write packages that do that but for your
domain so you have a much more natural
mapping between this and what you're
trying to do
and i got some interesting feedback on
this blog post it turned out that like
what i thought was that people were
really getting into the automated
validation side so you know they were
like
loving check test they're loving being
able to install and have the
dependencies come along which by the way
and this is not a robust way to manage
dependencies
and i talked a bit about that in the
blog post um i thought people were
getting into like having that all linked
up to github and having things fire off
on every commit
so it turns out that some people like
that but a lot of people like this
and i was like wow this was really
interesting to me i think i could give
like a whole
20 minute rant just on this subject um
so
this is the shortcut for devtools load
all in our studio
and you know people are using um our
package structure to get access to this
type of stuff
um and i think it's an interesting thing
because shortcuts
for automations that you make are really
hard set up in our studio
um they're a little bit easier recently
with the package made by um garrick and
dewey called shortcuts
but there's nothing in our studio itself
like you basically
we've got to write a package to do this
so people are kind of reappropriating
existing automations
to make their life easier but to do that
they have to use an up package
but they're just creating our packages
that they never plan to install
um so it's really interesting what's
happening there uh yeah so
i'll leave it there so what's project
isn't our package giving us i think
um a lot of admin stuff yeah so boring
like
cleaning my um our environment devtools
load all
all nice stuff like that um
use this beautifully handles all the
sort of file system admin
um again saving us a decision about
structure like here is a tried and
tested structure and you're pretty much
guaranteed to have an okay time with it
uh yeah and by the way there is a bugs
workflow it's not a debugging workflow
but you know the idea that you write
tests
you run them often and if you get a
problem you rerun sorry you
you write a new test that stops you from
having regressions i mean that's nice
now what's the problem i'm not going to
go into all these but it's just
all this niggling stuff that is not
related to a project but it's related to
a package and you've got to like just
deal with all these things
all the time um but i think the biggest
thing
is that if you have someone acts like
available to you
who could review your work who's a
domain expert and they know r
but they don't know our packages like
there's a fair bit of work for them to
do like a favorite of stuff for them to
get their head around
to review your work they've got to
become a package developer basically
and that's that just feels wrong like
it's the wrong way
to like make the people fit the software
you need to make the software fit to
people so that's my main kind of
thing all right so use projects as our
packages
yeah when you have something that you
want to archive for a long time i think
this is the main argument right like if
you if you're
if you have a reproducible research
object and you want that to live into
the future for a while
then it makes sense to use like a well
understood format for that
if you want to use the dev tools key
bindings like fine
but let's all be honest about that's
what we're doing you know
and maybe maybe if you acknowledge that
you can think about improving from there
so now i want to talk about target
graphs so in a target graph style
workflow
you break up your pipeline into little
chunks of work and you define this
dependency graph that relates to chunks
of work and we call these chunks of work
targets
and each one of these targets can be
like a data set or a plot or any kind of
r
object or a file and the idea is that
when i make a change
it's one of these targets my target tool
analyzes the graph and goes okay you
changed the histogram plotting code i
know that i only need to re-render the
report
and output the file all this stuff
beforehand i don't have to reload the
data set or manage it
um so yeah you can you can see that it's
going to save you some computational
time
and if you have like a complicated
target graph then that sort of
goes to another order of magnitude
because everything in these columns
represent targets that are not dependent
on each other so
these can be run in parallel and there's
some facilities in drake
and other target tools to do that so
that's that's quite nice but i actually
don't think this is the main selling
point of target graph
um i think you know one of the big
things is everything here is cached
and you can pull sorry i say cash i know
a lot of people say cash
i just like it's just a bad habit that
i've got into so i'm going to say cash
sorry
um so these things here are cashed and
at any point you can read them into your
r environment and play with them
interactively and that's super nice for
development because you know i can read
in this um
this histogram data and i can you know
work with it in the context of the
plotting code
so let's say like i get an error in the
plot i can quickly jump into the
plotting code
load the inputs from the case and i'm
away i'm debugging same thing happens if
like something important lands on my
desk and i have to immediately jump to a
different project
i can jump back to this project um and
load everything from the cache and i'm
sort of back you know with everything
ready to work on interactive development
the last thing i think is that you know
they these things have a similar
property to a notebook whereas if i
build this entire
um graph i have some reproducibility
guarantees
you know like the code and the output
are kind of synchronized
so that that's helpful
so here's some ways we can define target
graphs this is a make file this is from
jenny bryan's stat
545 course and this is a drake
plan it's a drake by will landau that
represents the same project but these
two things aren't equivalent
because make files are about expressing
dependencies between between files
and drake plans are about expressing
dependencies between our objects
and functions so you know this one has
some some intermediate kind of outputs
that don't need to exist over here and i
don't need to worry about handling them
and that's quite nice i just want to
point out some drake magic so
drake actually reads your code to
discover dependencies which is quite
cool so
you know if i like you're just looking
at this plan here that describes the
graph
there's nothing inside this report
target that references
histogram data or histogram but
inside the r markdown itself i'm using
those things and drake has like
because i flagged it in there and drake
has dived in there and found those
dependencies and registered them in the
graph
which is really cool and it'll do that
with functions as well
so what are we getting from target
graphs i mean
some pretty cool stuff like we can
quickly navigate to specific work
we're saved from waiting for code to run
all the time because we have vacation
that is easy like
it's literally like you you build the
graph caching is handled in the
background
no no there's guarantees made there's no
thinking to do
um we can easily set up a rappel for
debugging quickly so that's over here as
well
and or if we want to just resume work
and they save us from some
reproducibility failures this is a fair
bit of stuff i think
but one well there's a couple of
critical things um
target graphs is falling down in a
couple of ways like
you know we have to express the target
graph now and i have to learn how to do
that and despite looking like r code
like drake is a
sort of dsl in itself a domain
domain-specific language so
it is it is r but it has some special
drake things and i have to learn about
those and same with make files like
they're
a different language that i have to
learn but this is the big one i think
because target graphs try to be really
flexible they don't
they don't tell you what to do they
don't say look just put your things in
these boxes and everything will be okay
and i think that this is one of the
reasons that target graphs are not as
popular as they
kind of should be or would otherwise be
is is because
it leaves the user to make this decision
and to make this decision you have to go
and you have to read the drake manual
and you have to kind of
engage in this introspective thought
process um
and this is without the backing of a
brand like our studio saying no trust us
like this is the ways to do things that
will be you know enjoyable so it's a bit
of a risk
investing in this and it's kind of my
motivation for like doing a little bit
of a demo um later on i want to show you
like
it's it's not as it can be complicated
definitely but you can keep it simple
and still go a long way
so when to use target graphs when you're
building your pipelines with many
imports many input
many outputs and many intermediate steps
and that's like most data science
projects right
so yeah these are some examples for you
to check out now i just want to quickly
call out
this one so this is targets it's in our
package
and it's basically drake 2.0 so it's the
same author
will landau has written both of these
targets is quite new
um it's still i i would say it's not
stable yet
the other thing is it's not like targets
is like better in every way
than drake like it makes a difference to
the trade-offs and it's just
for most things it's better for some
things it's not in it so it really
depends again on what your priorities
are
so i'm going to show you a workflow and
drake and don't feel like that is like
completely superseded and outdated by
targets i think drake is still a very
valid choice especially now while
targets is evolving
um i think targets will kind of take a
while to mature um because will has kind
of made targets like to be an
engine but there's still like a ui layer
that can be built on top of that engine
and that will take a little while to
come
okay so drake and d flow what am i
talking about
so why did my team choose drake well
yeah i mean i guess like a lot of people
like we run these
massive um database queries and you know
millions of records
and yeah we share that platform with
other people who do like reporting type
work
so in order to be courteous um people we
don't want to run those queries all the
time we want to rerun them as little as
possible so we want them cached
then we had this works on my machine
syndrome
um coming in i really wanted to kind of
stamp this out so
you know i wanted to set up some sort of
like easy situation for my team where we
could you know just run this command and
the results you get are pretty much
guaranteed to reproduce in five minutes
time five meters away
because people were like running stuff
and sending plots and
attaching code and people were like
rerunning it and it was like either not
producing the same plot or like not
working at all
um yeah so that was getting pretty
annoying and i personally have been
burned by
the sort of scalability issues with our
markdown like cycle like i call it the
rmd monolith approach like just jamming
everything into the markdown file
i personally had experienced the pain of
that and not really scaling and so
yeah i was pretty ready to try something
else
so what's d flow so d flow is my attempt
to make drake more enjoyable for my team
and so that means like really looking at
where drake was like still
annoying and trying to paper over that
or make that nicer
so yeah i help with expressing the
target graph there are a few niggly
things in drake and i kind of make them
a little bit easier
um i save you a decision about structure
which is a huge one
like i say here here is the template
just use this and everything is going to
be fine
trust me um and yeah by the way there's
some built-in protection for like common
bugs that you might hit
what are the negatives well actually you
know i'm kind of like too close to this
to really think about the negatives so
i'm sure there are plenty but i don't
have a slide
um but maybe you know you tell me what
you think the negatives are
but i've written a like so that was like
the three or four slide intro um i've
written four thousand or so words about
this in this in this blog post and that
was kind of where the discussion between
jared and i started
so you might want to go check that out
and all i really want to say is like
this is a workflow by us for us
so take the ideas that you know make for
your own enjoyment and just leave the
rest
i think that's a pretty good principle
for workflows in general
okay so demo time so
what i want to do is i want to reproduce
that example from step 545 so it's a
pretty
boring example but at the same time i
don't want to show you like me coding i
want to show you my workflow
so i think that's i think i've made the
right choice here we'll see and it's
just a pretty
small pipeline that reads a file
containing words
and then it makes a frequency plot of
the lengths of those words so how many
words for length five how many words are
lengths six blah blah blah blah
and it it makes that plot and it puts
that plot into our markdown document
and um yeah that's pretty much it
okay so now i just need to check i might
need to switch up my screen share to a
different desktop so hold on a second
while i just do that
all right so you should see our studio
now
is that the case can someone just say
yes if you see our studio
yes all right thanks jared okay so we're
gonna we're gonna
do some stuff all right so i'm gonna do
it from scratch so you can sort of see
my whole workflow now i will just say
um i'm not a regular rstudio user i've
been using it again for like the last
couple of weeks
but i haven't used it for years so if i
do some stuff that's like a bit weird
and kind of outdated then you know why
so i'm here uh no what i want to do is
create a new project first because
that's the r studio way of doing things
um
so i have an existing directory
okay
hey jar just so you know you're not
muted and
i yeah yeah so i had some stuff going on
now here we go i got this empty project
right
and okay so like i said i've saved you a
decision to make
up let's see my fingers are quite cold
it's winter here so just
give me a second all along um i've saved
you a decision about
what to do with respect to structure so
we can just have a quick look at that
yeah this is a handy little function so
this is it
like pretty basic right this is where
all our r files go
this is a file that connects to drake
and tells it
how to run this work
this particular r file is the plan this
particular r file is
our packages so let's uh what's our
library calls
okay so let's um just go over here
go jump to say the plan
[Music]
so nothing in it right but this is all
kind of wired up so i can run this
there's an add-in in drake called like i
know you can't read that i'll just want
to tell you the name of the add-in
um it's called run a drake workflow and
so that
is this command it runs r make
and what r make does is it runs your
work in a fresh r session so it kind of
replaces devtools load all if you're
into the package workflow
it says you know all right fire up the
new r session and do all this stuff and
then run the plan
so i can run rmac right now um i've got
that bound to a keyboard shortcut so
control
m and drake will spin around i'll say
also it gets up to date because all my
targets are up today cool
um so let's have a look at how that's
wired up in the
underscore file so
yeah the responsibility of underscore
drake is to just set up the environment
for the running of the graph so i'm
going to load all your
package packages load all your library
calls run that
then i'm going to source all the files
in the r
folder so there's your dev tools load
loadable and
i'm gonna return the plan in a config
and then i'm gonna
build that conflict config so that's all
we do and if you just wanna see i'll
just
call it the packages. so yeah just a
couple of things
we're running conflicted as standard to
avoid um namespace issues
clashes i won't talk about that one
that's in the blog post um
and we've got drake so it's all pretty
basic so far so what are we trying to do
so um what i like to do
is to sketch out a high level plan
first so what do we need well we need to
have some words
and we'll assume that we have some
function to get the words
and what do i want to do with those
words well i want to
turn it into a data set if i can plot so
i'll have word lengths
and i'll just call that like make word
lengths
and that will be on words
and then what i want to do i want to
make a plot i said i want to make a
histogram so i'll have one
length histogram
made
should just keep it standard so i don't
trip myself up
nice and long and we'll do that on word
lengths
okay i'll just drop that down a bit so
we can
see what we're doing and then
we i said we wanted to make a report now
this is the thing that has a little bit
of fiddly
in drake so dflo has a helper for that
so i
do my use rmd i do histogram
let's just keep the same thing
links histogram okay
so d flow says i've done some stuff i've
added a doc folder i've added an rmd
i've added our markdown to your
dependencies and just copy this stuff
into your plan
and then i guess we'll choose a better
name than that
record okay so that's it
that's my plan now i haven't written any
code to do this
i've just said what i'm going to do and
this is the thing that i do
um i don't like i mean you saw a
complicated graph earlier i'm not going
to fully spec
that before i write any code but what i
tend to do is like if i know that i have
an output
i tend to write like a little chain of
stuff to get to that output i find that
process really really helpful
and of course like sometimes i make the
wrong design and i refactor as i go i
think oh no
like that should be two separate things
and blah blah that definitely happens i
don't get it right every time
but this is a nice simple example so
this is probably the right thing to do
one thing i want to say it's quite a
good pattern to keep the data munching
step
separate from the data loading step
because
you know this is the thing i'm going to
fetch from the internet um
and if it was a big thing like i only
want to do that once
but if i have that in the middle of my
munging code or mixed in
then every time i make a mistake which i
will in my managing code
then i'm going to refresh the data so
this is a pretty good path to use
okay so let's do an implementation
so i'm just going to jump over to my
presentation and grab the link but i
don't think you'll see that
that's all right that's just what i'm
doing
okay so where are we going to go
we want to go into here now i'm going to
use a shortcut to do that so you know
that shortcut in our studio jump to
definition
so i'm going to use that uh oh i thought
i was
oh no i haven't yet i haven't done the
magic thing yet sorry
so i don't have these functions right
they don't exist so i wrote this tool
called fnmate it's an add-in and it also
works with emacs
to create prototype function definitions
from function calls so i'm pretty happy
with myself um
so i'm gonna i have a have it bound to a
keyboard shortcut at the moment control
shift f so if i hit control shift f on
that
oh yeah
it says fnmate wrote you look at the
console it says fnmate wrote
ah get worse and if i hit on that
you'll write that one and now i've
written that one and now i have all the
pieces
and in fact let's just jump into one of
these
you'll see that it's just a stub but it
returns no
but all my functions were determined now
so they all have return values so that
means that i can actually run this
pipeline now
and there we go everything ran it needed
a markdown file everything's working
and if i look i have another shortcut
here there's a command in drake called
load add-in sorry the load add-in load
target at cursor
i think ipr that one yeah so and it may
not work now
oh oh that worked okay so
i load that target from the cache and i
have actually have another shortcut here
that outputs
um the thing that the cursor is onto the
console so
run that and you see that it's not cool
so everything's going to be null but
it's all sort of wired up so the game
now is just let's
let's get rid of the nulls so now i can
jump in here and that thing that i
pasted earlier will come in handy
so what i want to do i probably want to
do like a read lines
of that url oh yep
so there's that url and i can just save
that hit
control m to run the pipeline and i go
to error
okay what's my error drake's telling me
could not find function read lines yeah
because i didn't actually declare it in
my packages file so let's jump over to
packages
and that's a tidy burst thing in radar
so add in libraries
save that close that up run the pipeline
thinking thinking thinking all right
we're all good so
let's just reload that target so ctrl l
to me okay loaded that i'm going to
output it okay it looks like a vector of
words
nice all right let's go next one so jump
in what do you want to do with this
okay i got my words and i want to pipe
that
to
[Music]
ah so yeah yeah so what i want is to
create a thing
word lengths and what i want that to be
that to be is the lengths of the words
so run that yeah that looks like that
worked
there you go looks like a vector of
lengths and then
i want to make a table
and i want to pipe that to this this is
just a shortcut
to get a data frame it's a plot all
right now run that
oh what happened couldn't find pipe and
that was because even though i defined
all my dependencies i haven't actually
loaded them into my interactive
environment yet
so because that's a thing that happens
to me all the time i have a shortcut for
that so that's um
control p here so load the packages that
are okay
run that okay there we go there's my
data frame so
let's just uh run the pipeline again
make sure everything's all good run the
pipeline yep
okay let's jump back to the plan now
we're going into the histogram
all right so i probably should load
like low blood lengths from the cache so
control shift l
no control control l could not ah
see yeah i've actually probably
committed a feature to drake that has a
bug in there
so sorry i will um so if i jump so say
that
um let's just go back to the plans it
seems to sometimes not work which is a
bit lame
there you go all right so
i'll have a look at that one later
[Music]
all right so i want to pipe this to gg
plot
um now what i want i want the x i want
to make a tall histogram
so i want the um let's just have a look
at what this was
okay i want the word length on the x and
the frequency on the y
okay and i'm not doing anything special
i'm just going to make a geom
call all right so
run that yeah so it's popped up this
tiny histogram here
another little thing i like to do is i
like to run all my plots and have them
appear in a full screen thing
so i'm just going to shift this over to
my desktop blow it up
jump back because i hate having to like
adjust these panes all the time
um so now oh gosh you see what i'm
saying
oh man grab it yeah yeah so
i run that now i don't get anything
taken over my screen but i can jump
over here oh we get an error what's
happened
ah okay it decided to
that's weird yeah
okay let's close that arm classic
so usually what this does is it will
make it over here yeah
cool so that's the way i like to work i
like to have everything full screen and
just like
you know not have to be adjusting stuff
all the time okay so
but this is done and you can see x11
because you're not sharing that screen
it's on another screen yes
okay sorry good all right so what i'll
do is i'll kill that
because that's going to be annoying
and for now we'll just make do with a
tiny one here
cool sorry yeah that's an oversight on
my part
now i'll rerun the pipeline
cool that seems like that worked so we
jump back
and now the final thing so actually
we've got the histogram and we just need
to make the report
okay so like i said earlier um drake can
look into the report
and see targets being used and then
registered with dependency
so jump into the markdown file
okay so the way that we do that
is oh there's a couple of functions in
drake one's called load
so there's word lengths there's a data
set
and i probably want um word
lengths histogram
so let's just check that that works so
that works yep okay so that loads those
things into my our markdown environment
so they can be used um and and drake
will kind of spy on spy them
and register them as dependencies so
here i want to insert a new chunk
which i don't have a keyboard shortcut
for but do that
okay and i think i think the way that
this was set up in jenny bryan's example
it was like
some text there were um
so it was like some word lengths
dollar track so how many words are in
the input
oh my gosh yep what's
in the input cool
and then in here the histogram's just a
gt plot object right
so i don't have to do anything fancy i
can just say word
links histogram and let knitter do all
the magic
and turn it into a plot so i'm going to
hit ctrl m again to run the pipeline
oh i've done something
um
wide lengths histogram not found
okay this is good it's good to get
mistakes
so i called that word link system
control l
yeah histogram did i make anyone see did
i make a typo or something
no target
ah
that's a bit interesting did i not
save that or something boy
you have a plural plural you have a
plural issue
do i what do i have versus words length
oh thank you yeah see like you know the
pressure's on when you're doing the demo
and you just you lose the ability to see
stuff like that
and that was not me if you're people in
the con i don't take credit for catching
it a few other people caught it so no
thank you kind of user so words length
histogram yeah yeah oh
geez see always be consistent all right
so
i'll rerun that
okay so that's how it worked and uh
that's it
so kill that um jump back to the
markdown
okay so that's all pretty much working
now i think it looks like our markdown
document was rendered
so what i should be able to do i'll jump
back to the plan
and if i load this one this gives me
access to the path so i jump over here i
can go browse oh you're not going to be
able to see it of course
but what i can do is do browse url word
lengths
report and it'll pop up
the report on another screen which you
can't see
but that's okay
uh can i get it in a viewer or something
oh actually what i can do
i fly hits this is another thing like
because
um
so i can make this work with the knit
function like if you want to use the
knit button in our studio
what i need to do though is i just need
to like source my packages
and i need to include here to do that so
that's going to be
a little bit mixed let me just like do a
little quick hack sort straight
source tidy verse
that should be enough right so if i do
that
and then i knit this
there object drag now okay oh what am i
doing i want to say library oh sorry
again total spot
slightly embarrassing um all right so
knit that
and that's because um oh again it's it's
popped up in a different window that you
probably can't see right
yeah classic all right so i'll stop
trying to do that
um maybe maybe i can just
i'm just gonna accept that you don't
need to see that go to your options and
change it to pop up in the viewer
instead of a new window
options yeah options global options
yeah uh our markdown
then where it says show output in window
change that to viewer
a little lower sure oh man thank you
like i said i'm a bit of an art studio
noob
um all right
yeah all right so that's what we're
doing all right now things i want to
reflect on how much time do we have
am i over time or it looks like a couple
of minutes hey you're still good
you're good okay okay so what i want to
reflect on
a couple of things so you just sketch
out
a high level plan like this and not have
to focus on implementations
but also the fact that we've broken down
things into these like kind of
bite-sized pieces that just
that has so many kind of deep benefits
and i've written a bit about them in the
in the um the blog post
but you know i guess one thing i can
quickly show you is like if i jump in
here
and make an error okay so
um stop
okay so let's run that
yeah so i you probably can't see but i
just um
i tried to run that pipeline and i got
an error
oh yeah we're on a different thing now
yeah so
we've got an error just start studio
because
um because i will have to reshare my
screen but let's just restart my r
session
so let's imagine that i've just like
opened up our studio i'm coming in cold
from yesterday i had that error
so what do i do like i run the pipeline
just to see what's going on
oh yeah i had that error where was the
error it was in make word lengths
histogram so jump in here and i know i
can quickly just like
load the dependencies from the cache so
load that one
yeah start running the code i uh load my
packages
start writing the code okay made the
plot
no that's all working oh yeah that's the
error delete save
rebuild is everything fixed
everything's fixed i find that so useful
um to be out of context switch and to be
able to quickly
find you know where errors are occurring
it's like having an always on debug
helper type thing um and the other thing
is like did you notice that i didn't
have to use these file panes at all
the file pane to browse files like this
this plan
describes the structure of my project
and i was just using that using the jump
to definition to find things
um so like it's almost like structure it
doesn't matter like this is the
structure
the file structure doesn't really matter
as long as everything is wired up
i'm using the underscore drake file um
and the other thing is
is that when you're working this way so
we often have like three or four people
working on something like this
simultaneously and we so rarely get
merged conflicts and i think that's
because
where emerge conflict is going to happen
it's going to happen here in the plan
and if it does like everything's really
simple here it's just like okay
um i need to rearrange these function
calls or i need to delete that one or
you know you added a new argument
whatever it's quite easy to see what's
happening
and then if because all the work's
happening
sort of individually we're all working
inside these individual functions
that's pretty much zero chance of
getting a merge conflict unless someone
else like jumps in to fix a bug or
something but
um i did a typo there i just saw uh
sorry about that
um yeah so like that's really nice as
well
um so yeah like i said just before i
just want to reiterate i'm not saying
this is the workflow you should use
but maybe you've seen some my ideas
maybe you know you've seen some places
you can take your own workflow
um to help make things kind of more
comfortable um yeah
i hope i've kind of demystified drake a
little bit like drake
is deep don't get me wrong you can take
it a lot of places but i'm
using like maybe five ten percent of it
in this
um maybe more than that maybe twenty
percent of it in this demo
and that's like the twenty percent that
i use most of the time i rarely ever use
the dynamic stuff
um because um it makes the debugging
stuff a lot easier if you keep
it static because you know this
target name can appear inside my
function and i can load it from location
all that kind of stuff
all right so that's it i think i want to
wrap up there so thank you all for
watching
um yeah happy to take questions here
happy to say questions on twitter like i
love talking about this stuff
um so yeah thanks very much
so thank you very much for being here if
this were in person we'd be giving you a
round of applause
so instead just sit here in silence for
about 10 seconds while we all virtually
applause for you
ten seconds might be excess i'll give
you five
okay wonderful thank you very much
everybody thank you
thank you miles uh we have a few
questions right some people are
applausing in the chat so thank you
folks for playing along
uh roaring applause even better
so i've compiled a few questions here um
as we go if you ask more questions i
will do my best to
grab them so
first we have a question um what about
workflow tools like
nime and date iq dss
so i have no idea what those are name is
uh
yeah so name is an old like um
machine learning data processing
platform and then i say old i was really
big in the 2000s
and date iq is like a data science
studio they they essentially make a dag
it's a gui that you drag and drop dags
you can plug in different things
so i guess yeah um i mean i i i
i guess it's just a personal preference
i'm i'm very much not about gooey tools
i like to keep everything in code and
that's because i like to keep everything
in git repositories
um and so yeah for me that would never
work but i i do get that like for people
who are domain experts
um those types of tools can be really
useful um
yeah i i think if they give you the
benefits of caching and the ability to
quickly kind of drill into issues and
problems like
like you see with the drake target craft
and i'd say like if that's
where your teams are you've got mainly
domain expertise and not much
programming expertise that'll make sense
um a lighter question before we get into
harder ones uh what's the correct
pronunciation of cash is it cash or cash
oh i think it's cash but i've been
saying case since i was a kid like i
started using computers when i was like
you know like seven or eight years old
and i would read cash and i'm not
not having anyone ever having heard
anyone ever say it and that's just like
stuck
so yeah i i say cash sorry everyone now
when someone asked that question
actually a bunch of people in the chat
went off
and it seems like all the aussies are
saying cash all right well there you go
you might not be alone on that one yeah
all right
um what was the and actually this was
answered but i want to make sure
not i'm not sure everyone saw it what
was the package that you mentioned that
made it easier to create shortcuts
oh yeah so that's fn mate um so that's
on my github so f and mate i'll link
everything um that i've used here so
i'll put together a little bit of a
github
repair that has my slides links to the
packages and also my key bindings so you
can see exactly what i was doing
um yeah so don't worry that's coming and
i believe actually they were talking
about the shortcuts package
the shortcuts package that's garrick
aiden bowie's shortcuts package so you
can find that on his github and i think
it's like
s-h-r-r-t
cts um so the shortcuts without the
vowels
yes of course that's another one all
right and
since you mentioned fn mate um do you
have an example of how you do the
detailed documentation of an fn mate
creative function do i have an example
oh i mean
not to hand this is my personal computer
on my work computer but
um yeah it's it's just the oxygen so we
use the oxygen template
um and mainly i focus on documenting
like what i expect the arguments to be i
don't
really write you know big descriptions i
just focus on like this is what the
inputs are expected to be and this is
what the return value is going to be
that's the main thing i do and it
doesn't matter whether you export the
function or not like you're not doing a
package but
i think the oxygen format is still quite
nice
um how do you deal with like during the
development process you
you typically work interactively but
yeah and it has that jive of tricks i
know that if you
load d a an object you have to it
invalidates the cache you start all over
again
yeah so i mean like as you saw i'm
running r make so
there's two kind of makes in drake
there's regular make and then there's r
make
um so just plain makeover i should call
it um so i use r make because
it's always running in a separate r
session so it can't really interact with
my local development environment
um so yeah you're never going to get
accidental invalidation
or stuff like that happening so speaking
of our make a follow-up question
how do you pass in arguments let's say
parameters that came from our markdown
document
that you're using interactively how do
you pass interactive objects into an
rmax session
oh see i like i feel like that's quite
different to my workflows so
you want to pass parameters to an r
markdown document so when we've done
that
we've just had the parameters appear in
the plan as like
other targets you know so it would just
be like a target that is a literal value
and that gets passed as a parameter into
the r markdown document
and so it still works you know with our
make that's how that's how we've done it
okay since i'm not on our studio user i
i think there might be some r studio
context there that i'm not quite getting
like maybe our studio has a wizard for
it is that kind of the idea
yeah what i was referring to is um
situations when you have parameters from
our markdown document like i have
personally and so i can
give some color to this person's
question um
if i'm debugging and i'm not using our
markdown i will create a list of
parameters
just in a has like if interactive do
this if not don't do it this way doesn't
mess with the parameters
and then i want to have the plan pick up
on that because if it was ran inside of
our markdown
it would be run but if it running
interactively i need to make sure those
parameters exist
all right yeah i mean well the if you're
using rmac you would be running in
non-interactive mode and if you're using
mic you'll be running in interactive
mode so i guess it's just making a
choice of which one you want
okay and can you use our make
i guess you wouldn't use r make from
inside of an markdown document you'd
have to use that strictly from the
console whereas make itself you could
run inside our markdown
yeah okay cool
uh we have a question about
your coding environment you mentioned
you haven't used our studio in a while
so what do you normally use for coding
yeah i normally use emacs i've been
using that for sort of two or three
years
um and that was mainly just to try and
be more keyboard driven um i'm someone
who gets a lot of rsi
so i was trying to like build basically
like work without paint
um and yeah emacs and vs code are
experimented with a bit and sort of
settled on e-max
and you do know that um our studios
emacs key bindings
they do but the joke is that i actually
use vim evil mode inside
um emac so it's all hodgepodge of stuff
and
also awesome they do but our studios key
bindings um are a little bit limited for
me
um so i'm actually like in the process
of discussing a feature request with
them i
probably will never get it approved but
like um i like to have one called leader
keys so you can press like
key combinations in sequence you don't
have to stretch so you might have like
one of my like um someone have like
comma m
r or something like that and those kind
of work in our studio but you can only
do two
you can't do three so it's like deal
breaker
i've actually heard um uh radford neal
who wrote pretty quick r
he had a similar comment that he you
shouldn't have a shortcut defined by a
key combo should be a key combo defining
the shortcut so lets you create whatever
you want so you have more than the same
more than one shortcut for the same
command
all right then continuing onwards a lot
of these are about your process
what was the keyboard shortcut for
running the plan
i just had that so that's i've just
bound that right so i just had that as
control
m you could set it to anything um
there's an add-in in drake that gives
you access to that so the add-in i think
we saw was um
runner drake workflow so you could just
create any binding you wanted to that
okay um someone actually is asking to
see can we see all of your shortcuts do
you like them saved as a text file
somewhere
yeah yeah so so our studio has them in
our text format and
i'll i'll add them to the repo that i
thought i released for this talk
so you can see what they all were
shortcuts are very popular
yeah uh let's see oh could you show the
dependency graph that you made from your
plan
oh damn it yes i totally meant to do
that
um yeah okay so now i just have to go
back and show you
my screen i have like a giant like thing
on my on a piece of paper here saying
show the dependency graph
i still didn't do it
okay yeah so there's a few different can
tell me if you can see our studio can
you see it
yes okay so um there's a few different
ways to do this in drake
well there's only there's two ways it's
like do you want the r version which is
um use the underscore drake file or do
you want the other version so i want to
use the understood underscore drake file
so that should have popped up in the
viewer
yeah let me just try and blow that up
for you
maybe yeah
there you go so that's roughly the
dependency i think it is it's the
dependency graph that i had earlier
on the slides although i seem to have an
extra oh yeah
with the rmd file i got
no i don't know it's basically maybe
i've got one more function
another one i have yeah i think i think
i do
um and they're all green because they're
all up to date but if i was to make a
change i could invalidate one of the
like make a change here these ones would
go to black
someone's actually asking can we see
what the dependency graph looks like
when there's been an error
oh yeah okay so let's try that
so we run that so get the error
okay moving on with the dependency graph
yeah so there you go so i've never
actually seen this i've never run the
dependency graph with an error but
that's quite cool we get the big red dot
here's where you should look that's nice
yeah that is nice so when i get errors
that's uh
it's nice to be able to see it sometimes
it's hard to read the error codes
okay then we have a question give an
example from your work where jake has
really saved you time or money
and also can you tell us about some of
the deadlines you run into in the
context of your work
some of the deadlines oh yeah okay
and um yeah so um i guess
i mean for me the big thing is um
context switching um so that that comes
into the deadlines thing so like
um last year as you all probably heard
like massive season for bushfires in
australia
and that meant that in addition to my
regular work i was getting all these
like panicked requests for different
types of reports and stuff and because
like we were like all hands to the pump
i had to jump on that and i was doing a
lot of context switching and in
particular
i had to make a lot of maps i'm very
short noticed because like um
there's this uh political process in
australia where like if you have a
disaster
you've got like the local council has i
think like either 60 or 90 days to lodge
a claim
to the government to get like disaster
assistance funding um but they have to
provide proof
so i had to like had all these like
councils like you know
hassling um my team for maps that would
show like where the fires were where
they went and what they burnt
um and it was very much like jumping
from project to project to project to
project
um and then sometimes jumping back
because people would be like oh hey you
made this map but like you forgot this
or
you know can you put more in about this
so the context switching thing i'm just
like being able to jump into a project
and use that project's cache that
already existed and not have to like
rerun stuff and just make quick changes
and then get out
something that i could send to someone
like i think that saved a lot of time
yeah um but just in general i think that
the debugging thing like the way that i
can quickly drill into errors and find
problems i mean i'm not sure the amount
of hours that that saved me or money
that saved me but it would be a lot
great um so here is an
interesting one about docker and
containers oh yeah
does drake allow you to separate its
parts in such a way that
parts could exist in different folders
or containers does all need to be in one
location like shiny
yeah so this is like i'm not a big
docker user mainly because like at my
work we just can't use it
we have like an old um security setup
and docker can't communicate with docker
hub and stuff but um
yeah i i'd say drake's pretty flexible
right um and when you say parts
i'm not really sure what you mean you
mean like different inputs and outputs
and stuff
i'd say yes because like drake can you
know read
read inputs from anywhere like it's just
r code i can read inputs from
um anywhere over a network so i can read
inputs from a dockerfile
um can i run code from inside another
docker file um
no that would be really awkward um uh
no probably possible i guess i'm just
sourcing an r file right so as long as i
have a path to that docker file that
would work yeah
um so i think my answer is yes
um that yeah i couldn't provide any
support
for you for doing that but that seems
like it's possible
but if but enough people ask you on
twitter you'll learn so you could answer
to answer all right
probably yeah all right yeah so docker
is very popular obviously in the
not just the data science community but
other places and a lot of these
part of me i said yeah that's right and
i would use it if i could
so we tend to lean a lot on the wsl
because we can't do darker
now i know a lot of like these other
tools uh depend on
like airflow and other ones and there's
airflow and ml flow rely heavily on each
part of your being a separate docker
container so i know that is something in
with drake's parallelization
uh capabilities i bet you someone's got
everything about
dockerizing parts of it oh yeah right
well that's where i think like if that's
where you are you're better off maybe
looking at um
targets than you the new sort of
iteration of drake because that's been
built
more with this kind of use case in mind
and i know that will land out i was like
actively talking
to the um metaphor developers about like
ways to sync up drake and metaflow
um so that's where i'd start oh sorry
sync up
targets and talking about it and it's
interesting
interesting to measure security because
i know some security experts aren't a
huge fan of what the
security that docker offers and a lot of
just like squint your eyes and hope
nothing happens
so yeah um so then we have someone else
asked related to that
do you ever have a situation where you
deploy your drake projects to a remote
compute cluster
or do you just run them locally yeah so
we do we do
we have not very many but we have
deployed them to aws we don't so so
drake is that's the awkward thing for us
i guess is
drake is like got some beautiful um
abstractions for hpc so if you're an
academic and you use like traditional
hpc sort of high performance computing
you know clusters with sort of
schedulers and slurm and all that kind
of stuff
drake like has really good on-ramps for
that
we have aws so it's much more home brew
not as easy and so actually i tend to
fall back to just like
using a really big instance and just
running the project there
which is you know pretty much just check
it out
on the instance and run it like i don't
have to do anything extra to do that
and when someone asked that we actually
had um henrik
come in and say drake supports
parallelization via futures
and future supports as you just said
parallelization via linux containers
and henrik uh this is my way of letting
you know that you are the november
speaker at the meet up
and you are you can give a talk all
about this and um
you're laughing this way it's simple as
that sometimes someone comes up with a
good idea and they're the speaker so
uh we'll talk to you in november we'll
we'll track you down thank you
um that's the way it works folks
sometimes um miles got dragged in
because he was on twitter
hamrick has dragged him because he came
to the meetup you know sometimes we're
shameless like that
um let's see uh oh yeah well someone
else
uh piped in w-i i can't see their name
uh it might be will landow actually
speaking
i space l and he says that drake can up
another answer draken uh will you're the
december speaker
uh jerry can leverage the future package
of parallel computing
and futures can run in docker containers
oh and other options around the whole
pipelining container
an interesting um i will actually post
this for um
december will um you say run the whole
pipelining container but i'd be
interested in putting each individual
piece in a container because i would
like imagine you get this into
kubernetes and
each piece could be running in parallel
as needed um
that's something that you'll have to
talk about in december and you folks
think i'm joking we're going to
find you and make you speak soon all
right
all right so with that i don't see
there's any last-minute questions
usually when i say okay that's all the
questions someone chimes into the last
minute
so knowing this i'll give everyone a
chance to chime in at the last minute
and uh and see if there's any more
questions
then we'll just sit here um nicely each
other a bunch of people saying thank you
as you well deserve
tough one tabs or spaces
oh i mean spaces it has to be spaces
doesn't it
oh six we know from stack overflow that
you earn more money when you use spaces
and by assuming remap your tab key to
give you four spaces yeah
absolutely um the tab key but the type
key makes spaces that's that's how i
roll
and we see oh another question came in i
didn't see it thank you amada
what are the next steps for drake and or
disadvantages
um where do they go from here to learn
more
about this uh after your excellent talk
where do they go besides your drake post
yeah so there's the drake blog post um
the drake manual is is quite good
i just think the drake the issue with
the manual is that it's quite long and
has a lot of different chapters and like
it feels like oh no like how much of
this do i need to know
but hopefully now i've just shown you
that you actually don't need to know
that much
um and maybe like that was my like hope
is that i could give you a kind of like
boost up to go like this is just what
you need
um and now you can feel more comfortable
reading the drake manual
um i will say this about the direct
manual um i've read through it i think
twice now
uh with the exception the dynamic
branching chapter everything else i've
read twice
actually it's a fast read um it's long
but if it
will if you wrote that it's uh it's
nicely written
really high quality there's a few drake
videos i think linked in the manual as
well if you wanted to get like a bit
more bird's eye view before you jumped
in
um and i actually will give a really
great um our open side
webinar a few months ago now and that's
online that's really really good as well
nice if you're gonna post that we could
put it into the slack channel for
everybody
okay cool there's actually another good
question i missed earlier
how would you describe your our skill
level when you first got your job at the
fire service
were you an expert then or did you learn
a lot on the job
um i i would not class myself as an
expert now so i'd say i was sort of
intermediate um you know i have written
a few other packages so i know what i'm
doing
um but definitely with respect to
workflow i never had to think about that
before
so yeah i mean i had to learn i had to
start thinking about workflow when i
started this job because what we were
doing
wouldn't scale and i'd never worked in a
team at this closely before
so all that stuff i had to learn on the
job yeah
and how were you relative to your skills
when you first started the job
oh um yeah that definitely improved like
in in terms of like
in workflows and stuff i'm way better at
like plots and maps holy
you know geospatial stuff like that's
been huge yeah
so improved in in ways yeah
i feel like maps are so huge right now
like um we had in the
past year we've had workshops from cass
akimoto a professor at columbia
for gis he actually giving workshop this
week on gis we had edzer
besma the author of the half the stuff
give a workshop for us
uh it's mapping is just really getting
hot right now
yeah i mean it is really accessible
enough so yeah yes it is
yes it's very accessible uh we have
another great question here what do you
think the learning path is for someone
who's new to r
to get into drake so not just an average
r user but a newer user getting it to
drink
yeah i think you you have to want
what drake offers um and you have to
just start using it in your projects and
i think the thing is like
a lot of people go like oh yeah but my
project's not big enough to use drake
well it's not now you know in the
beginning you know how everything's
going to work and it's all like small
and tidy but things grow
and grow in scope and that's where like
if you start with drake when things grow
you'll be having a much better time
um so it's like anything like you have
to have you have to be motivated to do
it by an actual use case so if you have
a project
just say the next project i'm going to
do i'm going to use drake and then
you'll you'll learn from there
great so let me just check
um all right
i think that is everyone is going to
give
10 more seconds to see if someone types
that doesn't give them much time but you
know we ask a lot of questions
normally at this point we say if you
have more questions come to the bar
so i guess if you have more questions
since we can't go to the bar
although i do encourage everyone to have
their own virtual alcohol or
non-alcoholic beverage as you as we go
through this
um please ask questions for me but you
know oh which one
i'll i'll have a cup of tea nice cover
for me
it's it is it's 10 am there uh for the
conference this week usually off we
usually serve
alcohol and tea and stuff so this year
we've actually sent out uh coupon codes
for everyone to
get uh just kind of whiskey and matcha
tea for this
to make it uh better for everyone since
we can't meet in person that is cool
yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun like we
put a lot of effort into this conference
like normally it's like
it's a bit of a party so trying to bring
the party to people's houses
yeah we've got to attend in person one
day yes hopefully you will make it
you'll be able to i'm a lot of showing
the program
hopefully we'll be able to hopefully
next year let me know what actually hey
let me know if you're going to be around
during the conference and b
you got to speak in person in the meetup
when you actually make it to new york
we've had like in the past year we've
had three or four australians speak in
person
so there's no excuse for you now yeah
it'll be so much fun
ahmad is showing off the program we
actually have printed programs and
mailed to everybody
who's in the states at least
try to make it feel like home for
everybody because we because we miss
people
uh we have actually now someone else
typing another question coming in so if
you don't mind answering two more two or
three more questions we will
stickers yes stephen howe yes you got
today we we mailed
people stay heck stickers to make them
feel like they're their person
let's see another virtual conference do
that yeah i i think i think this is the
most dedicated recreation
i've heard of yes we're really trying
hard because
it's a fun time it won't be it's all
about that human connection so try to
make that connection still
so while steven is enjoying his stickers
when working on a project that also uses
python
would you use reticulate and drake or
make d or make files in python scripts
you don't use python at all i'm guessing
no i don't either no so sorry
i can't answer that question all right
when i answer your question carlos i'm
sorry
um oh yeah one more thing about the
conference since we're talking about it
we have an
art auction at the conference uh so we
have four or five paintings that pisa
art not just paintings these are art
that are made by members of the
community
and we're having an auction and all the
proceeds are going to go to the r
foundation
so anyone around the world can uh bid on
these things
and you win the you win the piece of
artwork we ship it to you and we donate
the money
to the r foundation so go so good cause
so
further recreating this in-person
environment mm-hmm thank you
yeah the stand-up comedy set will also
be very funny
it'll we have a comedian doing jokes
about math and statistics
only nice yes so folks
this is what you got to look forward to
during our week for those of you who are
attending
uh so with that on just a quick note
about this meetup you just watched
um the video will be up on youtube in a
few days uh might take a little longer
this week it's a little bit of a busy
week
and we are going to
um get slides from miles and we'll post
it at nyhakar
another question here oh got two more
questions i'm
one one asked me have we had have we had
rob hindman give a talk
not only is he here right now he gave a
talk in person and gave us
a workshop in person a few a year or two
ago
and he is the very first speaker friday
morning
at the conference so yes we love rob and
he's definitely
partaking in this community i just want
to say i i'm pretty sure that i've
recently converted rob hyman to drake
too i mean he can clarify
but i think i've got him on board nice
nice so yeah you're you're proselytizing
very well in this thing
um russia do you use to use a particular
package for spatial temporal
data i mean
i mean sf yeah all the sf stuff
what's the the one gt spatial also love
it we do a lot of static maps
gg spatial is great um also the
interactive stuff map deck
that's been really really great i don't
know if you guys are familiar with that
one but map deck is a
sort of mapping to deck gl yeah and
i will say uh there's a leaflet package
add-on called leaf gl
which allows you to plot millions of
points on an interactive leaflet map and
have it render in seconds
i haven't i haven't tried it but i mean
i trust anything written by tim aberland
so
it is tim um now tim will be very modest
to tell you he didn't really do it he
he's just putting rapper code around
this uh other person whose name is
escaping me
but tim is a genius he he made it
amazing
all right with that i think we answered
all the questions everyone had
about drake about other people about
everything uh someone has
the package for leaflet is leaf gl uh
i'll just type it in the chat
so it's easy to see it's not on cran yet
it's only on github
but i've been using it for a few months
now and they're they've taken a lot of
actually my feature requests
they are great and really responsive
they're super awesome
um so we talked about mapping we talked
about drake we talked about conference
we talked about australia
uh we talked about members of the
community has a great talk
i want to thank miles who might have to
go to work at some point i don't know
it's it's in the morning there for him
yeah i'm going to work pretty much
directly after this okay great working
from right here though so it's it's just
open up a new window and
sure community makes it easy it makes it
very easy
all right so thank you very much and i
hope to see
everyone as much as you can at the
conference our next month's meetup
remember
september will be about the command line
we have october planned
uh now henrik has agreed because he said
he laughed he said he'll be speaking
november hopefully we'll in december and
we'll see everyone else
going forward and hope everyone has a
great time once again
virtual applause for miles this is
really great thank you so much
thank you all that was really fun thank
you thank you
all right everyone have a great night or
morning or afternoon depending where you
are in the world